you
you
it covers more than 70% of the Earth's
surface the ocean is the planets
lifeblood but it's being transformed by
climate change every day
Darwin travels from the pacific islands
of Palau to fish on the northern reef
the reef is very important to us
you see that's our way of life our
culture before we used to please on the
wrists inside the river but now the
corals die and it's not much fish on the
reef that's why we're and into the
deeper water the blue work if I cannot
find a fish then the family is not going
to survive much in Palau
for years Darwin's made his living
around the coral reef that formed the
heart of an underwater community
colonies of tiny animal corals hosts one
in four of all marine species but
they're dying over half are gone already
the rest facing extinction on a scale
that could lead to devastating changes
for the ocean the planet and everyone on
it
in Hawaii a group of scientists dedicate
their lives to saving corals the cost of
doing nothing is enormous because we
could lose one of them are significant
ecosystems on our planet oceans are
dying our reefs are dying sometimes you
want to screen and shake people you wake
up and look and pay attention they are
pioneers using cutting-edge technology
and methods to help corals make a
comeback in the lab right now we're
doing some tests with a call Oh in the
life right now we're not allowed here
five minutes okay five minutes dr. Ruth
gates have been working to preserve
corals for the last 26 years oh look at
that that's cool that set up over there
they're measuring sort of business and
restoration area for the world in my
first dive on the reef I dropped my
regulator out of my mouth
I was so awestruck by this underwater
garden that was before me stunning
stunning architecture so busy so
beautiful today what we're looking at is
a semblance of that past self it looks
like a battlefield there's nobody home
it is devastating to watch the death of
the system you laugh before your very
eyes it's not just the beauty of corals
that's being lost reefs provide crucial
protection from storms of food or
resources for 500 million people even
the air we breathe up to half the
planets oxygen comes from the ocean and
the corals within
should we be doing everything in our
power to protect coral reefs at this
point the answer is yes because in
protecting them we're essentially
protecting ourselves
once a rich man's playground and a set
of the famous television series coconut
island is now on the frontline of the
battle to save corals it's home to a
group of young researchers like Ginny
who work under pioneering scientist dr.
Mary harden in the Hawaii Institute of
Marine Biology when I was a kid I wanted
to save the planet and I think this is
this is part of the way that's going to
happen
Ginny is part of a team whose approach
owes less to the secrets of the ocean
and more to human fertility treatments
at the reef the team collects sperm and
eggs from the corals then rush their
samples back to the Haggadah lab we have
this rat know if we firmly we develop
them in our lab even on a seems like
sort of makeshift contraption is
actually very well thought out and
really this is everything we need to
freeze our girlfriend we use technology
that was developed in human fertility
clinics and frozen a lot like human eggs
which is interesting the plan is to
create the largest repository of corals
in the world the type of Noah's Ark for
corals but that's easier said than done
we worked to try to freeze these for
seven years it took us seven years to
figure out how to freeze them the whole
process will take about four minutes
[Music]
we need to compare like this and asunder
like and I can seem short and don't
forget our diamond here minute yep
school so once the samples get down to
minus eighty then they all get plunked
into liquid nitrogen these samples will
stay in liquid nitrogen for at least 10
minutes and then they'll get transferred
into our storage containers and
theoretically they can remain there and
be stable for hundreds or even thousands
of years when I started we were making
an insurance policy for the future when
I twelve years it's gone from being
creating this insurance policy to
creating a bank of material that needs
to be used right now it's a race to
harvest the basic building blocks of
life before these tiny animals die okay
with the rain but the reproductive
habits of corals don't make it easy
reproduction for most world's only
happens once a year just a couple nights
and only a few hours of tonight so it's
a really limited window of opportunity
to get that material frozen and Bank
down cryopreservation of coral was
pioneered by the head of Jeannie's team
and there are still only five people in
the world dedicated to this painstaking
task we banged down quite a few coral
but we're still under twenty coral over
the eight hundred girl in the world you
know we still have under twenty in our
bank
our quarrel we really provide so much
for us so what's going on there is
really more about what's going on for
all of us if it ceases to be your ceases
to function the way that it's supposed
to it's going to make it so that we
can't function the way we're supposed to
either it really comes down to not just
a problem with the ocean but a problem
with our planet that will eventually
impact us
climate change has caused our ocean to
rapidly become warmer and more acidic in
Palau a chain of small islands in the
Pacific marine biologist
Jim nan Goldberg is studying the impact
on coral reefs
we're doing a survey of the paste corals
the damage was some places almost 100%
in some cases not as much Jim yang is
monitoring harm done to the corals here
that has now been found on reefs the
world over it's the tiny algae living
within each coral who really feel the
heat of climate change these plants like
organisms give reefs their vibrant
colors were traumatized by ocean warming
they're forced out killing the coral
they leave behind
but in a nearby Bay M Lang has made an
extraordinary discovery beneath the
surface here the corals are flourishing
the mystery that displays all the t-boz
hopeful that we can somehow war favor
our forth
you have a lot of these folio squirrels
there's a massive coral the branching so
what we'll do is just get in there and
each a swim get ready and just jump in
game nine found that the corals in this
particular Bay seemed immune to the
effects of climate change we started
this coral reef monitoring program where
we go around to different places in
following way and we monitor the reef
and look at risk conditions we found out
an eco bay area they recover really
faster so that told us of course here
are a strong and they're not flexible to
warmer waters we wanted to to try to
understand how were they able to survive
in this kind of an environmental Jim
Nantz research revealed that the waters
here have been naturally warm to
millennia it's not the heat itself
that's killing corals it's the trauma of
the rapid change in temperature over
hundreds of thousands of years
corals here in recovery have naturally
evolved to gain these resilience to
warmer temperatures and more acidic
conditions it's important for us to
understand how did that happen and if
there's specific genes that allow these
corals to survive can we use that
information and maybe breed for that
gene in different words again we
transfer that to other words in other
places it's an urgent task
over 90 percent of global warming in the
past 50 years has occurred in the ocean
and with water temperatures rising at an
unprecedented rate
evolution is fighting a losing battle
they scientists have decided to give it
to home a solution that we're proposing
is controversial because we're talking
about human intervention engineering dr.
Ruth Gates has a plan to speed up
evolution by creating super corals
capable of surviving climate change
please could I get the silver cup right
back so I can actually have coffee
before we get in water today
Ruth is looking for the healthiest
corals on the reef to work with corals
here are amazing this is our natural
laboratory coconut island is over there
we're looking to identify the strongest
corals on the reef and then use those to
develop cars that are even stronger that
can save climate change
[Music]
let's find that God bad luck put it on
how's that this piece is really a good
example of awesome amazing true
dimensionality they're not just
beautiful for the Hat so how huge number
of other organisms
but they also act as natural to long
lots of great waters really cutting the
energy at large storm that could come in
that would allow the land directly on
them
[Music]
route takes a sample of the strongest
looking coral on the reef
[Music]
to the circle
yeah came out on demand we had two huge
circles that was Gmail that was really
nice the specimens are taken back to dry
land where Ruth has created a type of
coral Jim here corals and confinement
are exposed to conditions that simulate
the effects of ocean warming in the
future these experiments are really
firsthand our goal is to give Carl's
experiences but stress them out of it
but they don't kill them and we believe
that that experience gets fixed as a
memory and the next time we see that
similar stress they don't see it as
stress they to see it as something that
used to seeing after the corals have
gone through an excruciating training
regime Ruth and selectively breed the
best of them like pedigree dogs have
been bred for centuries all of these on
the products can you see the round
plants those are all offspring from
selective breeding we did in vitro
fertilization and created the next
generation of calls that have been
selectively bred
the super corals are then taken to the
reef where Ruth hopes they'll now have
the ability to deal with the strength of
climate change this is the cutting edge
of a science
exciting work you know it gives me hope
that we can do something to generate
biological capacity to restore damaged
reefs but right now the pioneering work
of Ruth and others is just a drop in the
ocean until their methods can be applied
on a global scale there'll be huge
challenges ahead for the oceans bearing
the brunt of climate change for the
coral still facing extinction
and for the men and women across the
planet whose lives will be transformed
it's not likely to be so I'm going to
fix this in two hours
that's a lot of time for such a few fish
we won't be able to fit everybody and
same fishing before we know it it's all
gone
[Music]
will this strategy alone be sufficient
for all places absolutely not we have to
think about protecting places that are
doing better than expected
the reefs in the world that are these
hopes are perhaps most importantly I
think that we need to come together and
think more creatively about what our
science can do or decisions will have to
be made and we will have to let go and
make difficult decisions about some
species and even potentially some places
we have got to start acting now if we
have a hope of preserving and sustaining
reefs
you